hello I'm excited to show you this
course where we're going to use react
hooks to create a video player and
Thomas Valen Faulk and I will be your
guide in this course so what are we
going to build here we're going to build
this video player it's fully responsive
and we're going to create this list of
videos where we can select the video and
also have various kind of night mode
here if you want to shift the color for
a light theme to a dark theme and we're
going to use style components for all
the CSS styling here and I'm going to
show you how you can use different
theming and stuff like that so I'm
really excited for you to see this
because I love these new hooks and I
also think style components is great if
we go to the react site we can read a
little bit of hooks here at the time of
the recording of this course they're
fairly new so they're not an official
release yet so I have to use this alpha
build or react to have access to the
hooks but that's okay we'll go through
that in a bit we're going to install
this so don't worry about it so we're
going to use the state hook and the
effect hook there's a lot more hooks and
you can read about them here at the site
you can also create your own hooks I
think the effect hook and the state hook
are the ones you're going to use in 95%
of the cases when you code so they're
the most important and they will kind of
replace the state in the class component
and the lifecycle methods so with this
once we can have stayed and kind of
lifecycle methods in our functional
components there's no need to use class
components and that's great they also
say that it's great because if you kind
of knew to react you don't have to learn
all about classes and things like that
you can do your stuff we just functional
components so it should have a less
learning curve as you don't have to go
that deep into JavaScript classes well
with that said let's go through what
we're going to need to create this
application we are going to use a
library called react player it will give
us some nice functionality like cool
backs when playing the video and
callbacks when the
video has played and things like that we
could do everything ourselves in an
iframe but there's a lot more coding so
it's better to use this library and we
have all this for free so when I create
it from scratch what you don't need to
we're also going to use as I said style
components and the style components is
really great because it's almost like
creating regular components in react but
you create like CSS components we'll get
to that when we get there I'll show you
that in a later video and we're also
going to use the react router for
routing or videos because if you look up
here you can see we have a unique ID for
each video so if we click another one we
have another ID and we use routing for
that in that way we can just copy this
link and paste it somewhere and we'll
get directly to that video so it's great
if you want to share a link or something
like that that's why we're using react
router you could do this play without
the router and just change the video
here and it will still be at the main
domain here and not change the route and
of course you can style this whatever
you want later maybe there is some few
things that could be better here with a
styling and yeah you decide what taste
you have and what you want to do with
that later let's get on with it
installing over dependencies we need for
this if we go back to our terminal we do
a CD and we have to go into our starter
files directory so make sure you
download the starter files and it's the
folder that's called react hooks video
player start at end so CD into that
folder it's really important that you're
in this folder you can rename it if you
want it doesn't matter but do it now
before you start doing anything and make
sure you're in that folder and then we
just do an NPM install as this is an
to mediate course I assume you know how
to use the terminal and am/pm and all
this stuff so if you don't you probably
should take a starter course before
taking this course I actually have a
starter course where we create a movie
application so you can enroll that
course if you want to learn the react
stuff the basic stuff before you do this
one well my firm just went crazy here in
the computer I hope it doesn't bother
you too much so you can hear what I'm
saying
well let's get on with it we have to
install or react player so we write npm
install - s react oops
layer then we need to install or react
router and we do that by MPM install - s
react ro there Dom and lastly we need
our star components so NPM install - s
style components like so and press enter
and that should be it we should be good
to go we just take a quick look at the
package.json file in the folder as I
told you before we're using the 16.7
alpha version so that's what I want to
show you now it's really important to
use this version of react otherwise the
hooks won't be there and as you can see
or dependencies has been installed here
also so we should be able to just write
NPM start and this should fire up or
application here at localhost 3000 it
should open up automatically but if you
don't to go to this address here and it
says start here as we see this here we
know that our app is working so we can
start building things so we can also
just take a quick look at the folder
structure for a project so we have as
usual we have a public folder where our
index dot HTML file is I've only
imported a frontier from Google that
we're going to use for this one and I've
also created this kind of in
he'd an input field where this it's a
little trick you're going to use to get
access to the videos in the player we
will get back to this when we'll get
there I'll show you this trick later on
and we'll set the source folder there we
have our index.js file and we have our
components folder I created these ones
for you so they are empty now and we're
going to fill these ones up with code we
also have a folder called hook we're
going to create a high order component
I'm going to show you how to use that
and we have a containers folder with our
app and this one is just the start here
that we see I created this one so it
just started up something here and the
playlist stamp is empty the playlist
items is empty and this one is the main
component for the app where most of our
logic will go and I also supplied the
styles for you here because I think this
is a react course or not to CSS course
hey it's kind of boring seeing me
creating I'm writing CSS a long time
here so we're going to create two maybe
one or two of these when we go through
the style components and the other ones
I'll give you for free so you don't have
to do that by yourself
so I think this is it we're good to go
we have our local host up and running
here and we can start scaffolding out
our application in the next video
all right we're going to start
scaffolding out or components and the
structure of this application so we're
going to create a lot of functional
components here and we just create some
basic stuff in there now so we're going
to come back to all of them and finish
them later on so we can start with the
WBM player yes WBM is short for vibin
they call me Valen because my name is
Bateman [ __ ] so this is my player I'm
doing so I selected to call it WB I'm
player you can shake the name if you
don't like it I don't care so do
whatever you want so we're just going to
create regular components regular
functional components so we import react
from react and in this one we also going
to need a video and a playlist because
the video is the kind of window where we
play the video and the playlist
is the playlist to the right in the
application it will look at it he have
it no I have it there yeah so this is
the playlist and here we're going to
have a night mode component we're going
to have a header component and this one
is also container
it's the playlist items container and
this is each a playlist component of
these ones here and this is the video
component we are using here let's go
back to our application so we import
video from dot dot forward slash video
and of course we haven't created this
ones yet so it will give us an error if
we save and try to run our application
right now so bear with me we'll fix this
in a second and we import the playlist
from and this one is going to be dot dot
four slash containers and playlist
because this one is a container and the
other ones are just presentational
components and they go outside the
containers folder then we create a Const
wbm layer props on our function like
this and also make sure you have the
casing right on everything we do in this
course because I know there's a lot of
people having trouble sometimes and it's
in 90% of the case it's some type error
or it's the casing here that's different
and it will throw an error if you don't
have the casing exactly like I write it
here in the video so make sure you have
everything correct and check it twice if
you got some error when you try it later
on and this one we have to have a return
statement and parenthesis and we're
going to return the video component and
the playlist we're going to change this
a lot in the future videos because this
is the main component most of our logic
will go here so it will grow and have a
lot more code and we export default WB
and player like so and we can save it
also
we have some error here and that's
because you can't return to components
we can create a rag fragment here and
you can just use this this is shorthand
for react fragment so you can just write
it like this like so we can copy all of
this code we can move into our playlist
component we paste it we input react
these ones we don't need but we are
going to need the playlist header and we
import that one from dot forward slash
playlist header like so we also going to
need a playlist items and we grab that
from dot dot forward slash containers
lay list items and we going to need our
night mode also and that one we grab
from dot forward slash night mode like
so and this one is only going to return
JSX
so we can omit these ones and remove the
return and make it nice like that first
we have our night mode component then we
have our play list header and then we
have our play list items there's a
typing error here it should say playlist
items and of course we have to rename
this one also so we call it playlist and
that's it we say that one and we can
copy this one and go to playlist items
paste the Korean we can remove this one
we are going to import our playlist item
from dot dot forward slash playlist item
we can remove the night mode and we're
also going to import the high order
component in this one later on but we'll
say that one
for a special video about this we rename
this one to play list items and export
it as playlist items of course and in
this one we're just going to return a
playlist item for now like so we can
make little nicer and we save it so this
is our container components we have our
app we have our playlist or playlist
items we have our main component the WB
and player Deus so let's move on or hi
our component we say this one for later
as I said so we go through our
presentation or components we can paste
our code we can remove all of this and
remove these ones here for now and
rename it to night mode like so now we
can just create a div for now here every
write in light mode say this one and
actually we can copy this one we go to a
playlist header rename this one to play
list header and that's enough for this
one also for now so say that one and
move on to our playlist items paste the
code and rename it to play list items
playlist item not witness save it and we
go to our last one the video das paste
it and you probably know it but now we
should rename it to video like so and
for this one we can also import our
react layer so import react player from
react player like this and this should
be it we have all our components
scaffold out now and it
going through a pas and import WBN
player from and this one is just going
to be one dot and /wb m player and we
can return that component here like so
and we save it go back to our
application and as you can see it's
working because it's showing the text we
wrote in the different component so we
know that our structure of working in
the application in the next video we're
going to finish our apt of j/s and talk
a little about routing and react your
router it's time to start coding our
application from real and we're going to
start by creating our routes we're going
to need for this one so we're going to
be working in the app top JS file for
this video
we need a browser router and the routes
because we want every individual video
to have a unique link so we can go
directly to it in our video player so
that's why we use in routes for this one
let's start off by importing everything
we need from the browser router so
import browser router and we need the
route and we need a switch and we grab
them from react router Dom we can delete
this one we won't need it
instead we create a new component called
browser order and we wrapped everything
in that component and inside we create a
switch and we can start creating your
first route and it's going to be an
exact match with a path to the route our
component are going to be the WBM player
and what this will do is when we go to
the route here in my case it's vaping
Falcone's last react underscore video
player it will start the application
from scratch so in this case now you see
it's going to another route here that's
because I played a bunch of videos here
and it remembers that I was on the video
7 I'm going to show you this in a later
video so don't worry how we do this
routing
how it remembers where we left off the
last time so this is kind of the first
time when you go to the video player and
haven't played anything then it's going
to stay in the root and not forward you
to another video ok let's create another
route it's also going to be an exact one
and the path is going to be forward
slash : active video so you probably
know this as this is an intermediate
course and not the starter course so
what this will do is create kind of a
variable for us we call it whatever we
want in this case it's active video and
it's this ID up here by calling this one
in our application we can grab this ID
up here so the component will be guess
what it's going to be the exact same
component for this one and why is that
yeah that's course we don't want to
change the view here we just want to go
to different videos but have the same
view so we're just using this so we can
get this ID and use it in our
application make sense I hope so
one thing you also could do here is to
create kind of a not found component I
haven't done this now so if we for
example go into another directory here
it won't show us anything or if you
write the wrong ID it won't show us
anything either so that's kind of an
exercise you can do if you want just
create another route that will fall back
to a not found component when the routes
don't match okay this is actually it for
this video it's a short one and in the
next video we're going to talk about
style components and how it can use them
to style our applications ok we're going
to talk a little about star components
in this video and also start coding with
star components if we first go to the
star components comm we can check out
what star components are and yeah it's
visual primitives for the component age
yeah use the best bits of es6 and CSS to
style your apps without stress that
sounds wonderful you should also know
that there's different opinions about
star compo
and what you should use creating react
applications or you maybe should use CSS
modules or regular CSS I happen to like
star components and I wanted to try
using it in this course I hope you like
it if you don't like it you can of
course implement another styling for
your application you can read everything
about it here and I suggest you do it if
you're interested in in star components
in the future the basic idea here is
that you create components with your
styles so you can use the Stars just as
regular react components if we look at
the basic instructions here we have to
import style from star components we've
already installed style components we
did that in the first video with the NPM
install command and then you create
these cones and call it whatever you
like it will be a component to use for
you later on and then you create your
style as a regular CSS so the only thing
you may be wondering about here the
these backticks and it's called
a tagged template literal you can
basically invoke function with backticks
instead of parentheses and they write
all about it here and this is not a star
component specific it's in es6
JavaScript so you have to look this up
if you don't know what is this so I
suggest you do that also if you're
interested in learning more about es6
and javascript and as you see rewrite
the style inside of these backticks and
it will create a component for us to use
in our code and that's the basics of
style components and we're going to go
to our code editor and start coding or
first style component if we take a look
at our starter files you have a
directory called Stice I choose to
separate this out from the main
components and have them in their own
file and there's also different opinions
about this some like to have them in
their component directly but I think
it's nice to do like this to kind of
separate them in their own files but if
it's a large application it may be good
to have it in their own components so
you know exactly where you have the
styles for your component as always to
do as you
want I'll choose to do it this way
because I like it and I think it's
fitting for this application and this
course alright we're going to work in
the app top JS file this time also and
we're also going to work with a global
style yes in the Styles folder because
now we're first going to create the
global styles for the whole application
if we look at the global style yes I
already provided these for you we're
going to delete it now if you don't want
to do this if you don't want to create
CSS and if you don't want to do all
these things with star components you
can just keep this because this way you
can just import these in the components
later as we're going to do and you don't
have to write your CSS at all so they'll
eat these ones and we start writing some
code here again so we import something
called create global styles from style
components and this is something as it
says we can use to create a global stars
it's in the star components library so
we use this ones when we want to create
global stars then we create the Const we
can call it whatever we want and I want
to call it global style for this one
then we use create global style it
shouldn't be on s there it should just
say create global style then we create
backticks and inside these backticks we
write our CSS first we want to set
box icing to board a box in the whole
application then we have our body and we
set the font size to 10 pixels and we
set the font family - Hinda sans-serif
and this is the one I imported in the
index from the google fonts and this is
it for a global styling we just have to
export this 1x put default global style
like this we save it and as I said this
is takes AK code as we just deleted I
just wanted to provide you with this if
you don't want to do all this so we go
back to our app top guess we have to
import our global style that we just
created global star from we grab that
from dot forward slash tiles global
style and now we can use it in this
component and how do we apply the global
style to our application well it's
fairly easy actually in this case we
just create the component called global
style like so and this will apply the
global style to our application and as
you can see we have an arrow now and
that's because as it says the router may
only have one schoiar element so we'll
wrap this one's in a fragment like so
you see that the font size is less now
so we know that the global stars are
kicking in and this is it this is how we
applied global styling with star
components in the next video I'm going
to show you how to do the styling for
the individual components
we've finished our global styling and
we're going to continue to do some
regular component styling in this video
so if we go into the Styles folder and
into the style playlist we're going to
create the style component for the
playlist so as before delete this one
and we're going to write it from scratch
first we import style just as before
from styled components then we create a
Const called styled playlist and an
equal sign and style dot div and if this
for example should be an input box we
just write input like this or if you can
have what element you want here so in
this case it's going to be a deep so we
use the deep here and now it's just
regular CSS here so not that funny but
we have to do it so we set a flex to 1
don't know if we need to have these
vendor prefixes here but to be sure I
put them in so we're creating a flex box
here just for centering things in a nice
way if you're not familiar with Flex box
I recommend looking it up it's really
nice on you it's much easier to Center
things and vertical center and
horizontal Center and aligning your
items and we have a color of white for
that one and also if you're going to
have some other classes and things maybe
for example you want to have some
styling for different viewport and some
responsive styling you just write it
below here and you can have what classes
you want it's just regular CSS so you
can name some class and you just do like
this and write your CSS in here it just
has to be inside these backticks so for
example you don't want to create a
component for every little class you
have in this case we don't have other
classes we have one media query that
we're using for the responsive
functionality so we write media screen
and
max with 1400 pixels and we have a width
of 100% and display:block and finally we
just export this one also export default
style playlist like so and this is it
this is the style for the playlist we
save this one and we go back into our
playlist das file first we import our
newly created styled playlist from
doctored forward slash Styles tiled
playlist like so and then instead of
this fragment here we can just wrap it
in the styled playlist like so and if we
take a look here we can see that it's
not showing the other ones here and
that's because they right now we're
using a white color in the playlist but
they're there so don't worry it will
look a lot better soon right now it's
looking tragically sad but we're going
to fix this and we're going to do one
more just to make some exercise in this
one so if we go into our styled playlist
items in the Styles folder just as
before delete this one I think it's good
to repeat things because that way you
learn a lot faster and maybe it's boring
and you already have this code as as
Thole you can just save it and let it be
but I highly recommend that you do like
this and repeat it and just write it
because your brain will learn a lot more
if you write it down yourself so import
style from style components again we
create the const called styled play list
items and we write styled div this is a
deal also and we do two backticks
and we're going to write a CSS between
these backticks
and we have a padding:0 20px 0 and 20
pixels actually we can do like this like
so that's the shorthand for that one
we have an overflow why of all we have a
height of 20 8 VW a max height of 500
pixels right
then we're going to do some trick c2
style or a scroll bar and we have to do
some WebKit stuff here so : :
WebKit scroll bar we want a width of 5
pixels : :
WebKit scrollbar track and we set the
background to transparent and we have a
WebKit scrollbar thumb where we want our
background to be 8 8 8 & or border
radius 2 pixels and the last one : :
WebKit scrollbar thumb and hover and we
want a background to be a little darker
so we set that one to five five five
that's it then we export default styled
latest items and we say this one so I
hope you got to flow here now we just
import start and we create the cons to
name it whatever we want this is not
something specific to style components
or react or anything you can call it
whatever you want and we create our CSS
inside these backticks
here as I said before this is the
element you want to create the star
component for it can be whatever HTML
element you want so in this case it's a
deal we go into our playlist items das
we import
style lay list items from total forward
slash styles and styled playlist items
like so then we can wrap this component
in our style playlist items and we save
it and we have some error here module
not found okay there must be some
misspelling here from my side of course
this one shouldn't be there it should be
right there instead
bad mistake by me but alright
that's coding you know trial and error
all the time and now it should work
again still not showing anything
exciting here but it will soon get more
exciting I promise okay we can do one
more thing here before we finish of this
video we're going to go into our
playlist item is not items with an S
playlist item J s and for this one we're
not going to create the whole CSS for
this one we're just going to import it
here import start play list item from
dot forward slash Styles styled playlist
item like so and as you can see here if
we just check the CSS file playlist item
you see it's a lot of CSS code here and
we don't have to write all this now it's
kind of a boring the one thing you can
notice here is this special where we use
props here to change different values on
the properties of the CSS and we're
going to talk this in the next video
when we go through the theming with star
components so don't worry so go back
into our playlist item and instead of
the deep we just wrap this with styled
playlist item like so and save it still
not showing up anything here but it will
soon
all right so far so good this is the
last video in setting up the styled
components to be used in our application
we're going to talk a little about
theming and how we can use it to have
different themes in our app so let's get
started here we're going to be mostly in
our WBM layer JS file so make sure you
navigate in to that component style
components have something called a theme
provider and we can use that to switch
different themes in our application and
also we can use it to sort of set up
different properties that we're going to
reuse somewhere in our Styles it's
really convenient if you're for example
have some predefined colors then you can
just use those colors by fetching the
props for your component because the
theme provider will make sure that the
theme get passed down by props to your
component so first of all make sure we
import our theme provider so import
theme provider from style components so
we're going to create our themes now
first of all we have a regular theme we
call that theme it's just a regular
object here you can see we create a
Const named theme and it's a regular
JavaScript object so we have a beedi
color of three five three five three
five we have a beedi color item and that
one will be for one for one for one like
so we have a beedi color item active and
that one is going to be 45 c63 whoops
there's something wrong here of course
this should be comas here as its own
object BD color played and that one is
going to be five to six d4e and we have
a border it's going to be none and we
have a border played and it's going to
be none also and we have a color that is
going to be white so set that to ffff
all right that's our theme object and
then we're going to create another
themed object it's the object for the
light theme so we can just copy this one
and right below it we paste it and we
call that theme light and we're going to
change some values here so we set the BT
color to FFF white we also set the BT
color item to white
we set the B the color item active to 80
a 7 B 1 we set our B the color played to
7 D 9 9 7 9 really innovative numbers
here and you can of course style it like
whatever you liked for this one we're
going to have a border of 1 pixel solid
and a color of 3 5 3 5 and 3 5 and
border played it should say border
played there so make sure you change
this in both of the themes border plate
and that should be non there and the
color for this one should be 3 5 3 5 3 5
like so so this is our objects with all
the different theming styles and we have
this theme provider that we imported
from style components we can use this
one let's go down here to our return
statement
and first of all we're going to wrap
everything in our theme provider so make
sure you move it inside the theme
provider like so then we're going to
send in our themes so we have the theme
and we're going to set the theme based
on our button if you look here we have
this nice mode button here so our theme
is going to be based on how we have set
this button state so we grab that one
from state night mode and this is a
ternary operator here so if the state
night mode is true we're going to grab
the theme cuz that's the night mode
otherwise we're going to show the theme
light
like so and of course this won't work
now because we have no state yet and we
haven't fixed all other things so it
will throw an error now and we're going
to replace this fragment here with or
WBN player styles first of course we are
to import them so we grab them from
import style WB and player from dot dot
forward slash styles styled WB and
player like so and now we can use it so
we replace the fragment with style
WB and player all right we have wrapped
everything we return in our theme
provider and we have provided a theme
based on the state on our night mode
button we also have created a style for
the player component here so if we go
into our Styles folder and style WB and
player and this is how we can access the
values in the two themes we created in
the component so we can get again delete
all of this and we're going to create it
from scratch and we import style from
style components just as before and we
create a Const of style WBN player and
we use style that we imported and it's
deep this time also create two backticks
and we write our CSS inside of these
backticks just as before so our
background are going to be based on if
we have the light or dark theme and how
do we access this well in our WB and
player yes we use this theme provider
and supply the theme that means we now
have a prop that's named theme and we
can access all of these values in this
prop so we go back to our style style WB
and player yes and for a background we
grab or prop we do that by a dollar sign
and curly brackets we grab our props and
we grabbed it from props dot theme VD
color just as we named it in this
component here so this is the one we
grabbing based on what theme we are
using light or dark
we do the same with our border or props
error function we grab it from props
theme and border and that ones are just
regular CSS so we have a max width of
1800 pixels we have a margin of Cyrano
row we display it as a flexbox WebKit
box ms flex box and display flex we have
a flex direction over Oh a max height of
863 pixels we have a transition all 0.5
seconds and an ease like so then we have
a media query here for our
responsiveness so we have media screen
and max width of 1400 pixels we display
block and max height of 10,000 pixels
well this is CSS so you have to you can
try it yourself and see what all these
values does to the app and you also have
to export this one so export default
style w VN player that's all and save it
and that's it that's how you use themes
with star components one more thing
we're going to do in this video is we're
going to connect or different style
sheets here with our components so we go
through all our components here in our
app we've already all the style sheets
we need here we have the global style
and the styles for the individual
component in our playlist we also have
all our styles you know playlist items
we also have our styles in our WBN
player we have all our styles in the
night mode EAS we're going to import or
style sheet for that one so we import
styled night mode from dot forward slash
styles
night mode here we wrap this one with a
style night mode instead like so and
actually we can just finish this one as
we here we have a span and we write
night mode and a column then we have a
label with a class name of switch then
we have an input with the type of
checkbox we set the checked to night
mode which set the on change to a
callback function that we call night
mode callback and as before these are
not going to work now because we haven't
created this ones yet we have
span with a class name of slider round
we can just destructure the props here
also we have a night mode callback and
we have a nice mode and that's it for
this component and we're going to create
these ones in a later video so don't
worry say this one okay we have a few
more components left that we're going to
import or styles for so we go into our
playlist header yes and we import our
style playlist header from dot forward
slash styles styled playlist header like
so and then we import our styled journey
from dot forward slash styles style
journey and this is also quite a small
components I think we can finish this
off right now we have our styled
playlist header you wrap it in that one
then we have a P tag and we grab that
from a probe called active dot title
then we have our styled journey and also
active probe we grab the numb and we
have a forward slash and we have a total
like so and this is it for this one and
these ones here it is what you see here
this is the journey we have the active
video and the total video and this is
the title of the active video that's the
ones who goes here we can destruct you
the props for this one also the active
and the total like so so it's nice and
clean then we go to our playlist item
yes we already have imported or stars
for that one but we can finish this
component off also
and for this one you can see we're
sending in some props so we send him the
active and we send in the played like so
and we destructed the props we have the
video we have the active and we have the
played so if we go and check our style
sheet for this one style playlist item
you can see that the props we send in we
using them here also just as we did
before with the theming so we have these
props accessible for us and we can
change the CSS based on the props it
works the same way as I showed you
before here we have the theme and here
we also have the props that's called
active and also the props is called
played we're changing the visual of our
player based on the active video and if
it's played or not that's this one here
is the green dot here that's going to
show up you can check those CSS files
out as I said before this is not the CSS
course it's a react course so I'm not
going to go through all of these CSS the
most important thing here is that you
can use props like this with the style
components so I suggest you can go
through them and see how I've done it
here we go back to a playlist item dot
yes and finish this one of all so first
we have a deal with a class name of WBM
player underscore underscore video minus
number and we have the video and num for
that one can actually copy this one here
this one is going to have last name of
video name and this one is going to have
video time and here we grabbed a video
title and here we grab the duration like
so and this is of course these ones here
in each item that we are setting up here
so say that one and we have the last one
to go and that's our video we import
styled video rapper from dot forward
slash styles style video rapper and we
import style video from dot forward
slash Styles style video like so I
actually think we're going to finish
this one off also and we're going to
talk more about these components later
on when we are assembling the video
player with these components so we're a
proper active we have an autoplay we
have an end callback and we have a
progress callback we change this one to
style video and inside of this one we
have a style video wrapper like so and
our react player goes inside this one's
a rack player or the one that we
imported here and also installed with an
Pam earlier so this one will take a few
props we have a width of 100% we have a
height of one hundred percent we do some
inline styling here with this one it's
just a small small adjustment here we
have a position or absolute and top of
zero then we have playing we're going to
grab
on the prop out of play we have the
controls set to true we want to show the
controllers in the video you can change
these ones if you want we have an URL of
active video on ended we're going to
create an end callback and we have an
own progress callback also and these
ones are defined in the react player so
we're just using them as this say you
should use them we have to close this
one also and this is it for a video as I
said we're going to talk more about this
later on but I thought we could finish
them as we already here now first of all
we're going to correct some little type
error I did in the last video maybe you
saw it already done so we have corrected
it but in the playlist header yes and
where we destructure the props
it should say total not total total is
the Swedish word for total so maybe it
was that who made me misspell it so all
right with that said I thought we were
going to create some hooks by now but I
think it's better if we in this video
just finish off our components so when
we start creating a hooks in the next
videos it's better to have a working app
and not this kind of fail to compile
thing here and a broken application so
if we fix these ones in this video we
are going to at least have something
showing here when we create the state
hook in the next few videos so let's get
on with it we can start we have the
playlist and the playlist items left so
in the playlist go into the playlist das
and first we can destructure the props
we're going to need and we have some
videos we have the active we have the
night mode callback and we had a night
mode like so and for our night mode
component we're going to send in the
night mode callback like so
also have the night mode prop like so or
playlist header are going to get the
active prop and a total prop and we grab
that from videos length 10 or playlist
items are going to get the videos and
active also like so and we're going to
come back to these props and what they
are so say this one and we continue on
to our playlist items KS first we
destructor the props and we have the
videos and we have the active for this
one and we can delete this one because
in these styled playlist items we have
this list of different videos so we have
to loop through this list and create all
the items and we do that by grab our
videos and map through them we have a
video and an error function and inside
here we are going to return our playlist
item and it's going to have some props
it's going to be the key we always had
to have the key when we map through
something we had a video we have the
active and here we're going to check if
the active ID is the same as the video
ID and then we set active to true
otherwise we set them to false that way
we know which video that is active so we
have the video ID and we check if that's
equal to the active ID and then we set
it to true otherwise we set it to false
we set played to video dot played and we
close it like so and this is it for this
one and the last thing we have to do
here is to kind of assemble everything
in the WBM player dot Das and we're also
going to create empty callback functions
just so we don't get an error because
they don't exist
and then we're going to fill them out
and create them in a later video if we
go into our component we can create a
Const night mode callback and this is
just an empty error function we're doing
here now
then we create another one that's call
and call back like so and the last one
is going to be progress callback and for
now they at least exist so we don't get
an error thrown at us and in our return
statement here we are going to do some
coding also so first what we want to do
is to check if we have videos in our
state the state we haven't created that
yet we're going to do that in the next
videos so we're just preparing it here
so it will work for us later on so we
check that the videos array isn't null
and if not we're going to return all
this right under here we create the
closing parenthesis and then know if we
have videos we're going to return the
player otherwise we return nothing we
return now and we have a closing curly
bracket there also and we can do like
this and then we have to send in the
props to the video and playlist so in
our video we're going to send in an
active prop we're going to grab that
from our state that we're going to
create later so we have a state of
active video we have the autoplay prop
and we grab that from state or a play we
have the end callback and that's the one
we've created up here like so and we
have our progress callback
that's of course is this one light so
and of course this shouldn't be there so
remove this one we have it down here
and our playlists are going to receive
some props as well and for this one we
have the videos we grab them from state
of videos we have the active we grab
that from state active video we have the
night mode Kovac and that one we
grabbing from of course night mode
callback and I spelled that wrong also
this shouldn't be too C's so remove the
Seas and just have one in that one and
we have the night mode and it's going to
be from state night mode like so and
this should be it we should be good to
go what's happening here well we're
going to create a state with hooks in
this functional component and we have
our video that's this one and we have a
playlist components so in our video we
grab from our state the active video we
grab if it's older playing and we grab
or uncool back and/or
progress call back these ones are going
to be sent into the video component so
we have the active order play and call
back and progress call back here in our
video and we're using them to control
the video then we have our playlist and
for a playlist we have to have some
videos and we want to show if it's the
active video and we also have a nice
mode callback and a nice mode if it's
true or false and this one as I showed
you is the button for night mode and
here is our items in the list so in our
playlist we have or props that we sent
in from WBN player and we use them in
our playlist component with Sandin or
call back for the night mode and the
night mode if it's true or false and the
playlist header are receiving the active
video cause it's the active video we're
showing here it also receives the total
amount of videos in our list cause we're
going to me
here as we displaying the total and what
video we're on in the journey section
here and we have a playlist items that's
going to of course need a video so we
send in all the videos all the videos
from the array and we also send in the
active one because we want to highlight
the active videos somehow here the
playlist items are going to loop through
the list of videos in this array and
create a playlist item for each video in
the array so I hope this is clear for
you if you want to get the feeling you
can click through the components and
start with this one as this is the kind
of main component for application and
from there we send out props to our
different components down the tree this
is it for this video we should be good
to go when we create the state hook and
in the next video I'm going to show you
another example of react hooks and how
they work before we start actually
coding our hooks take a deep breath and
lean back in your share because now we
can relax you won't have to code
anything in this video we're going to
step away from the original application
we building and I'm going to show you
some basic concepts of the react hugs in
this video so I created this special
little application here or it's really
an input field where you can write some
text in that I'm going to use to show
you how you can use the hooks instead of
glass components and keeping state in a
controlled component so if we look at
the code here it's just a regular input
field that I've styled with the style
components and this one is the new ones
here it's the the hooks here that I'm
going to explain a little short before
we create our own hooks so as you can
see here it's just a functional
component and I'm creating the state
here with a u state hook so the benefit
here is that you don't need to have a
class component to have State in your
component and we import them from you
state and use effect from react and as I
said before you have to have the Alpha
build or react
that's called 16-point 7.0 alpha for the
hooks to work
when you create a state you do it like
this and for now I'm just going to show
you we're not going to write anything in
the next video we're going to create our
own state and then I explain it more in
detail so hold on we'll get there soon
enough
the basic concept is that you create
whatever name you want for your state
and you also have a second one that sets
the state here and this value here is
the default value so it can for example
be testing we say that one and you see
it says testing here in the input box
and for now we just want it to be
nothing this is the placeholder text in
the input field that I specified here
well so how do we use these well if you
look at this styled input we have a name
of test we have a value of state the
state is this one so we set the value to
state just as we do in a regular
controlled component in a regular class
and we have a norm change function here
that's called update value so in this
update value I just set the state to
each target value it's the value that
you write in the input field and then in
turn the use effect will trigger when
the state updates and for this one I
just gotten console.log know that
console.log outer state so if we for
example are going to write Star Wars
here I love Star Wars so I have to use
that as an example so we write the Star
Wars you can see here it's constant
logging out the state so there's nothing
special about that it works like a
regular state here you just have to
initialize it a bit different with this
I also create the effect state because
in this use effect we are now going to
set another state so you can have how
many hooks you want here you can have
how many states you want and your state
can of course also be an object just
like your regular state in a class
component but in this case it's just
this string and we'll talk more about
this later when we create a state in the
next video but for now we have these
kind of two different states here
so in the use effect we are going to set
the effect state with the state we use
the set effect state to set the value
that we have in this state and we do it
here you just call this as a regular
function and send in the value you want
to set the state with and then we
console.log the effect state just to
show what's happening here so say this
one and we try to write to us as you can
see here now what's happening here well
it's going crazy and why is that I have
to break this let's do it like this now
and save it why did it go and set the
state that many times like in an
infinite loop well there's nothing
strange going on actually because when
we set the effect here in the use effect
it's going to trigger the use effect
again and of course it will set the
effect state again and it will trigger
it again so it goes into an infinity
loop here and that's not good so how can
we control this if we do like this I am
comment out but we'll make this active
in this array here you can specify what
this use effect should be dependent on
if we write state inside this array it
will check if state have changed so that
means in other words if we have the
state here it won't do anything if we
haven't changed the state with a set
state because in the next loop here it
will see that the state haven't changed
and it will skip this use effect so we
say this one now and as you see it's
working just as before if we look at the
state here it's a star but it only says
sta in the effects it's always one
character behind and that's because it's
a sync when we set the effect state here
it hasn't update this state when we
console.log it out instead we can have
another use effect here if we copy this
one like so you can have as many as you
want and we want this to be dependent on
the effect state instead
and in this one we console.log out the
effect state so we remove this one here
and if we save and try this now we write
star and as you see it's always the same
now and it's not like behind with one
character all the time and that's
because this one will trigger when the
state has been set so we make sure that
this is finished before we console.log
it and we also make sure to not go into
this infinity loop by using this one
here and actually this won't go into an
infinite loop because we're not setting
in a new state in this one it will
trigger when we update this state also
so it will run kind of double yeah as
you see it runs it two times and that's
not good so we wanted to just show the
console.log when we update the effect
state like so and this is kind of neat
cause you don't need that class
component many people find the class
components more complicated than the
regular functional components and we use
this use effect instead of the lifecycle
methods that's on the class component I
think it's great because you just have
to think of this one and you can control
it by specifying what should affect this
one it's kind of new when filming this
video so it would be fun to see what
people will do with the hooks in the
future here I hope this gave is some
little idea before we go through and
creating our own hooks we're going to do
that in the next video and we're going
to start with a used tail hook for our
application alright it's time to start
creating some hooks finally bet you've
been waiting for this as my motivation
for this whole course was to show you
the newly announced hooks in react as of
recording this video so in this video
we're going to be in the WBM player JS
file and we're going to create the state
hook and if we go to the home page for
react es dot org and read about the hook
i just wanted to show you some small
things here before we start
noticed in the previous video that I was
using this syntax when we created a
state maybe you know about this already
because this is es6 syntax how a
destructor an array you can read about
it here also they're showing a great
example here of why we can do like this
when we create the state and you state
returns an array with two elements and
when we do like this we can name these
elements so this is the same as these
three rows here you first create one
variable with the you state and you send
in your initial value and this one will
return a pair and this is just a regular
array so we can access the values by the
zero and one to get the first and the
second value respectively yeah the using
the fruit example here so they assigning
to variables called fruit and set fruit
and you can call these ones whatever you
want I don't think I explained that in
the previous video with the setting here
it don't have to be named set but it's
very practical to have it like this
naming convention so you know that this
is the one that you said to stayed with
but you can call them whatever you want
so enough sad about that go back to our
coding editor and we're going to start
do some coding here and I just want to
show you I promised you in an earlier
video that I was going to show you a
neat trick on how we can get the videos
into our react player if we look at our
index dot HTML file in the public folder
and inside here you can see I've created
a hidden input field here and the nice
about this is that we can create a value
on this hidden input field and this is
like a JSON syntax here we can write all
our videos here and we can grab them in
our react place so we don't have to hard
code them in as we don't have a back-end
to upload or we don't have a database to
grab or videos from for our react player
so we can just create this hidden input
field and you can do this in whatever
HTML file you are going to apply this
player to just be careful here because
you can't just create space and things
and quotes you have to use these special
characters here otherwise it won't work
so this is simply the videos here I
wanted to have an I do
list because when we save it to local
storage it's good to know what playlist
we have saved there then I have the
actual playlist that's an array with
objects in it we have the video number
we have the title we have the video ID
after the title we have the duration and
lastly we have the video link so you can
add whatever you want here and this is
kind of neat trick to get the videos for
a player kind of a hackish maybe but it
works on as I said before if the things
work in this easy to do it there's
sometimes not bad doing things like this
you don't have to build a complete back
and complete admin system for this just
to get some videos into your player so
let's go back into our WBN player das
file and we're going to add these videos
to our state first we have to import our
state hook so we do that up here we
write the coma and curly brackets and we
have u state and we can also import use
effect right now because we're going to
use that later on alright let's go into
our component here and create a Const
that's called videos like so and we grab
our videos with the JSON and we want to
parse it we have a parenthesis we grab
it from document query selector and we
have a new parenthesis and a tick we
have a bracket name equals videos like
so and we have an end bracket and then
dot value at the end and this one will
give us all the videos in this con steer
so we just have to create our state now
we do that with the new Const brackets
we call it state and set state like so
and as I said many times now they don't
have to be called this that's cause I
choose to call them this you can call
him whatever you want and we call the
use state function and we're going to
say
our initial state with an object inside
here so we have our videos we grab them
from videos dot playlists we have an
active video and that one we're grabbing
from videos dot lay list and it's an
array so we're using the first video if
you haven't watched any video we're
going to set it to the first one we have
a night mode I'll set that to true cuz I
want a dark theme you can set it to
false and it'll show you the light theme
so it's up to you what you want
there we have a playlist ID and we grab
that one from videos lay list ID and we
have an autoplay that we're going to set
to false to start with and this is
really all there is to it it's just
these two here one that we save the
Stadion and one that we can set the
state with we will do that in the next
video when we use the use effect hook
also if we save this one it should work
now and of course we have an arrow here
playlist items we go back here and check
that one okay nothing wrong here so
we're going to replace doc yes and yeah
of course I forgot an S here so make
sure in your playlist dot yes file in
your playlist items the prop there
should be called videos not video it
should be plural so put an s on that one
and save it and it should hopefully work
now yeah we see it here now the first
time we see our player it's actually not
working now you can of course play the
video if you want but we can't change
the videos for now because we're going
to create these links here when we do
the higher-order component and also the
ninth mode
won't work now because we haven't
created or callback functions but the
player is there and as you can see it's
fully responsive and it's working and
looking great here now and that's good
in the next video we're going to check
the use effect hooks okay welcome back
you can see that I have a little bit
different policy in my editor and that's
because I'm recording this video cause
the
hooks have changed a little bit since I
recorded this course I recorded it when
the hooks wasn't officially released so
now they have some special rules here we
have to take into consideration and that
is in the use effect we have to define
all the dependencies and that's what
we're going to do also now in this video
if you see something in the videos after
this one that's yeah maybe not look the
same as this one I created here that's
because I have recorded this one and
this is the one that it should look like
so this is the correct video here
alright first of all we can go to react
the home page and check out the hooks
API and there you can see that they've
got some basic hooks and additional
hooks there's actually a lot of hooks
here and you can create your own hooks
also we are only going to use the you
state and use effect in this course
cause that's the only ones we need but I
highly suggest that you read more about
the hooks API here and also if you like
the hooks I'm going to work with them in
your future work I suggest that you also
read about creating your own custom
hooks because it's very useful I use
them a lot in my projects so that's the
key I think we'd hooked that you can
compose your own hooks and it's very
composable if you use hook throughout
your whole application ok that's that
we're going to create or use effect in
this video so let's go back into our
code editor and into our WBM player dot
JS file it's in your containers folder
so we create the use effect we've
already imported it up here and as you
can see I also done some destruction
here now in this component that's also
one thing I didn't do in the previous
video so we have the match and the
history and the location prop so you can
destructure them out like this
alright then we create our use effect
parentheses and we create an inline
error function here we're going to have
our dependency array so we can create
that right now all right on the first
thing we have to do is to get our video
ID and if you remember in our app dot JS
file in our route we created this param
and that means that we can grab this ID
with this parameter up here you can see
that we have this ID here and this is
the one that we're going to grab and
that's the one we call active video so
first we create the Const we can call it
video ID and we grab that from match.com
dot active video like so and that's
because we destructor it here otherwise
we have to put props in front of it but
we don't have to do that now so here we
grab the video ID from the URL and then
we have to do some if statement here
because if this value is undefined we
know that we're not on a video and we're
going to rock back to the first video in
the video list when you open the video
player for the first time then we don't
have any saved state and local storage
so we're just going to rock back to the
first video and we're setting that as a
default here in the active video it's
the zero that's our first video so we
create an if video ID not equals to
undefined then we're going to do
something and we're going to have an
else and inside of this if it's not
undefined we have to find the current
video in our videos array and we can do
that by creating a new cons first that's
for new active video we have our State
or videos and we can find index we have
a parenthesis and inside here it will
iterate through every element in our
array so we can do some comparing here
and find the index of that video so we
have an inline function the video we
compare the video the current video we
run in the loop the ID of that one if
that equals to our video ID like so and
that will give us the index for this
video that we get from our params
alright
and then we have our video we know what
we do with this so we can set our state
and we're going to use an updated
function inside of the state for this
one and that's because we don't want to
specify this state as a dependency in
our use effect because that will
create an infinite loop in our use
affect every time our state updates it
will run the use effect and as we set
the state in the u.s. effect it will
create this infinite loop but if we grab
the previous value in an updated
function inside of sub-state it will
just live inside of here and we don't
have to specify it in the use effect and
we get the previous state by this
parameter here so we spread the previous
state that's really important when we
using hooks the set state will not merge
the old state so you always have if we
want to keep it should be three dots
there if you want to keep the state as
it was before
you always have to spread it out
otherwise it will wipe out the state and
just to create the new values for you
but if we spread it here we keep the
state and we can set our new properties
here so we have our active video and of
course we also want to have parentheses
here like so and we have our active
video we grab that from Rev videos and
we set a new active video so we change
the video to the one we got here and the
autoplay we grab that from location
because we're sending this auto play
with our route so we can grab that from
props dot location auto play like so and
that's it if the video ID isn't
undefined we change the video to the
value we have up here so we grab this
value and set it in the state and this
will trigger an update so we change the
video in our list all right but if the
video ID is undefined we know that we're
going to route back to the first video
and we can do that by pushed to our
history prompt that we get from the
router so history push parentheses and
we have an object we have a path name we
have backtick forward slash and a dollar
sign and from our
state active video we grab the ID and we
am with another backtick and you also
going to set the autoplay to false
because we don't want the first video to
start playing by itself alright and as
you can see here now the linting rule
are complaining that we're not
specifying any dependencies so I guess
we can just auto format it like so this
one depends on what limiting rules you
set up for yourself so maybe this one
won't work for you maybe you have to
specify this yourself
depending on your limiting rules so it
tells us that we need a history we using
that inside of here we have a location
or a play we're also using that inside
of here we have our match perhaps active
video we're using it inside of the use
effect and with the state active video
dot ID that we use here and we have the
state
videos so they are not specified in our
dependencies for the use effect and this
was the new thing when they release the
hooks officially so if we save this one
and go back to our application and if we
go to the local host 3000 and not using
a video ID it should raft us to the
first video and it does so that's great
and we can't click these ones now
because that one we're going to do in
the next video where we create the
high-order component and attach this
kind of linked functionality to our list
items hope this made sense for you well
it may seem a little much but I think if
you take a look at this one or two or
three more times it will come clear to
you I think it's not that difficult what
we're doing here ok we're getting
somewhere here now and we're going to
create our higher-order component so we
can get these links to work so we can
change the videos in the video list so
let's go into our age OC folder or hoc
folder and/or with linked Jas file and
to be honest we actually don't need this
high order component for this to work we
could just go into our playlist item and
we could create a link here on the name
but I thought that I wanted to show you
how to create a high order component
this is an intermediate course and high
order components are useful when you
want to reuse your logic for different
components so my thought was maybe you
build another application where you just
want to show your video titles or
something and don't want them to be
clickable then you can create a high
order component where you can apply the
link instead and then you can use your
playlist item component for another
course without the link so this is the
truth you don't have to have this I
thought it would be great to show you
how high order component works the high
order component is a component that
either takes in a component as a
parameter or returns a component or both
of them in this case we're going to send
in our playlist item component and we're
going to create a new component with the
linked function applied to it
so it kinds of boost the other component
with new functionality but we never
modify the original component with
signing in as a parameter we're just
returning a new one
because you shouldn't do that in a high
order component you should always return
a new one all right
enough said in our widdling j/s let's
start with import react from react then
we import a link from react router dome
then we create Const with link rat
component that's the component we're
sending in here we have our props and
curly brackets and how this is going to
work is we're going to take him the
props and we're going to modify these
props and apply the link to the name so
we create the cost with new props like
so we clone or
props and we modify or video so this is
not an array in this one this is only
one single video so we have the video
and all the data about the video in the
video object this is not an array it's
an object this time
so we yet again clone the video object
and we modify the title inside the title
we create a link we link it to and for
this one we have curly brackets and
another curly brackets cause it's an
object inside here so we change the path
name to backticks forward slash dollar
curly brackets props video ID and an
ending backtick there then we set our
autoplay to true because we wanted to
play when we click the video and we
close that one and we have a link and
inside or link we grab our props dot
video dot title so we have wrapped or
title inside this link now then we just
need to return or wrap component with
our new props so we spread them out like
that with es6 syntax and of course we
export default or with link like so then
we need to use this component and if we
go into our playlist items yes for now
we just returning the playlist item but
we want to return the modified playlist
item so first of all we import our newly
created higher-order component from dot
dot forward slash hawk whit link we
created
Const lay list item with link make sure
that I don't have an s too much or
something it should be playlist item
with link yeah
and we use a wit link and sending or
playlist item so this one will give us
to modify the booster component to use
for us inside here and now we can just
change this one to playlist item with
link and it should work if we say this
so we go back into our application but
they won't work and why is that
yeah and that's because we should of
course return on new props here not the
old props go back to your wit link das
and change this one to new props
otherwise we're just passing by the
props and we're doing nothing with them
it should say new props save that one
and now we can click the links as you
can see here nice it's working great
actually
and as you can see the ID is changing up
here because we're routing it and we
changing this ID with our router so this
is how I do it with a high order
component if you don't want to use this
you can just apply the link in your
playlist item instead in a much simpler
way but in this way you can reduce this
component and we have just added
functionality with this wit link dot JS
file with this high order component in
the next video we're going to create the
callback functions that we set up here
so we get our full functionality of the
player okay there's not much left to do
here now with our player but we have
some few things left in this video we're
going to create the callback functions
that we need for the player we have one
when we switch the night mode on and off
and we have also one when the video has
ended when it's here I'm going to change
to another video and we're also going to
have a callback that sets the status to
watch on the video that means it's going
to indicate here with a little green dot
that we have watched this video and we
want to do this when we have played a
video 10 seconds so you just don't click
it and then it will say that you have
played it we want to know that the user
actually have watched at some of the
video at least so let's go back into our
WB mas file and first we create the
callback for the night mode and that's
fairly easy actually we have already
created this kind of empty functions
here so in this one we just have to
check a boolean if the night mode is on
or off and we have our night mode in our
state here for now it's true and we
should change it to false or true when
we click the button in our player so in
this one we actually just have to set
the state first we clone the state and
then we set the night mode to the
opposite of state night mode like so and
that's all we have to do with that one
based on that boolean we are setting a
theme here and selecting the light or
the dark theme
so we say that one and we should be able
to try it now yeah as you can see we're
changing the theme here now when our
callback function working and that's
really nice so now you can select if you
want a light theme or a dark theme and
of course as usual you can style them
that's whatever you want you can have a
orange team or a green theme or whatever
you want
all right and then if we just look in
our video TAS file we have two callbacks
on our video and these callbacks are
integrated in the react player so we
just use them as they are intended to do
in the instructions from the racks
player we have one prop that is called
on ended and one prop that is called on
progress one-handed is when the video is
stopped playing and what we should do
then so every time a video has reached
the end we get the call back from this
component drag player also we have this
own progress it's given us a callback
call every second of thing so we can do
some stuff on progress call back here
and we're going to use that to check
when we are played the video for at
least 10 seconds go back into our WBM
player dot yes and we can start with the
end callback here and there's a few
things we have to do here first of all
we have to know the index in the video
race of the video we currently playing
because we have this array here in a
state with videos and we going to go to
the next video or if we're at the last
video down here we're going to jump to
the first video and how do we do this
well if we go to public index dot HTML
file we have this num here so we num we
give each video a number so that would
be fairly easy to just grab this number
and take minus one on the numbers cause
the array starts at zero and this one
starts at 1 then we know what position
in the array we're at but we can't be
sure that the user always are going to
have these numbers in this file it could
actually say whatever you want here so
that's not a safe way for us to decide
where in the array the current video are
what we do also have is this kind of
unique IDs they should be unique
you could of course have the same here
but then it won't work so the thought
here is that we have unique IDs for
every video and we can use this to find
the index in the array so let's go back
to WBM player yes and in RN callback
first justice before we grab the video
ID from props match params active video
and that'll give us this ID up here then
we have a method that we can use that's
called find index on the array so if we
use find index in our state that videos
array we can find the index of the
current video so we create a Const
current video index and we have the
array in state dot videos and then we
use the find index method so parentheses
and now we have to do some comparing
here because we have our video ID and
we're going to look for that one in the
array so we have the video we have an
error function we have a video ID and we
just check if it's equal to or video ID
that we grabbed up here so this one will
iterate through every element in our
array and compare the video ID for each
item with this item here because we know
this one is the active video so when it
finally is one when this is equal it
will return the index for us in the
array all right I hope that was clear
for you then we have to do some more
shaking here and see what our next video
will be so we have this Const :
[Music]
if our current video index equals to
state dot videos length minus one we are
going to jump to the video zero the
first element in our array and we doing
this - one year cause as I said the
array starts at zero and our videos
starts at one otherwise we just set our
current video index to plus one
we jump to the next video and this is a
ternary operator here as you can see
maybe we can just do that this it's a
bit nicer so we know now what the next
video will be so we can push that into
our URL with the index of our next video
and we push programmatically by props
history push we have an parentheses and
where curly brackets we have a path name
backticks we have a dollar sign and
curly brackets again state dot videos
and we use our next video that we got
here and or ID for that video and we end
with another backtick so this one will
go into our state array with the videos
and use the index we got here in the
next video for the array and grab the ID
and we push that to the URL so we change
video and this one should of course be a
coma and we set to autoplay to false we
don't want it to order play when it
changed the video we just want to order
play when we actively click a video
ourselves and this should be it we could
say this one so if we try it we can take
one video here whatever and we go to the
end so we're at video two now oh it's
kind of slow here we play it and as you
can see it jumped to the video three and
it stopped there because we didn't set
it to order play so we know that that
one is working and now we have our
progress callback left to do and as I
said before what this will do is we'll
set our video to played after ten
seconds so first of all we have to check
if we played it 10 seconds so we create
an if statement if and of course here we
have our event and it's only one
parameter here so we can omit the
parentheses so we do like this and we
write if e dot laid seconds we get this
one from the video from the react
players we can check how many seconds we
played so we're just grabbing that one
from the event we get to this callback
if it's greater than 10 and we also want
to check that it's actually not greater
than 11 because we don't want this to
fire off all the time when we play the
video so yet again we grab a dot played
seconds and set it to less than 11 and
there we have our if statement and now
yet again we have to find the correct
video to apply this play the value to so
you can do this in a couple of different
ways one way of doing it is set the
state and then we can just loop over the
videos and when we find the correct ID
we just set that to true so I'm going to
show you this one now so we set state
parenthesis curly brackets we clone our
state we have our videos array we want
to update this whole array here so what
we can do here is we can map through all
the videos and we can update the element
that we want to apply the plate value to
so we just write state dot videos dot
map we have an element an error function
curly brackets and inside this map we
want to return something and we create a
ternary operator here we check if our
element dot ID equals to state active
video dot ID if it does we know that
this is the video we want to change
cause we playing this active video now
and we want to change or videos array
and set that this video has been played
all right and if this is true we update
this element so we clone the element
first we always have to clone it and
then we set the played property to true
for that element otherwise we just
return the element because we don't want
to modify that one and this should work
now so we go back to our video you can
see here this it's this green little dot
here that will get applied when we have
played a video more than ten seconds so
if we for example we have the second
video here and we let it play for over
10 seconds then it will apply this green
little dot here and as you see if we
change before the ten seconds nothing
will happen
it kind of tells us that we have been
visiting this video before and played it
and of course you can have more than 10
seconds you can have less than 10
seconds it's up to you what you want
there stop this one and I can also just
show you another way of doing this if
you want if you don't want to do this
map thing here take this one comment it
out you can just create a Const with
videos equals dotto top state videos we
clone or state here with the videos we
have a Const played video that equals
videos find and here we can now find the
correct video so we have a video an
error function video dot ID equals state
active video dot ID so here we grabbing
the video in our array that's equal to
the video that we actively playing now
then we can just apply the played value
to this one so we have the played video
dot played and set that to true and then
we can just set the state doctor top
state and videos so we created this copy
we cloned the videos here and we looked
for the video that we want to set the
plane to true we apply that one and then
we set the state with the complete new
videos array and it will replace the
other one so save this one and it should
work just as good so if we take this
video for example and let it play for
about 10 seconds yeah we
all right and 10-11-12 just to be safe
and you see it applies the green dot so
it's really up to you this probably even
more ways to doing this but now you have
two ways you can do it here and I hope
this was helpful for you and this is
actually or a complete player we just
have to create our local storage so we
can persist this data or what we have
played and or list with videos
okay we are almost finished with this
one and in this video we're going to
learn how to persist our state in local
storage the first thing we have to do is
to have a function that will trigger
when we have updated or state in the
player and for that one we can use the
use effect hook as we did before so we
need a use effect hook that triggers
every time the state updates so if we go
into our file wbn player yes yet again
and below our state we create a new use
affect hook use effect parentheses then
we have this error function inside like
so and we will access the local storage
I'm right to it here so we write local
storage dot set item parentheses then we
need a back tick dollar sign curly
brackets and we want to grab state play
list ID we want to save different states
in the local storage if we have more
than one player with different playlists
so we identify it with the playlist ID
and not a backtick coma and then we do a
json stringify course you can only write
a string to the local storage so we have
to convert this one to a string before
we write it parenthesis and we have our
state orbit so we clone that one like so
as we learned before we also have to
make this use effect dependent on
something and in this case we want it to
only update when the state changes so we
go down here write the coma create our
state like so and this will make it only
fire when the state changes so we say
this one we go back to our player and
inter console we can check our
application and inside there we have a
local storage oops just going to delete
my old ones here so I reload it and as
you can see we have this playlist called
WBN RDX and we have our stayed here as
you see so every time we change
something here it will also update the
state as you can see now it's the active
video it's number three here
and now it's number four so it's working
it's updating the local storage and sync
it with the state what we have left to
do is when we initialize the player we
want to check if we have something saved
in local storage and use that stayed
instead so we create a new con stopped
here called saved stayed and we get the
young to add JSON we parse it back to a
JSON format local storage get item
parenthesis backticks dollar sign curly
brackets and we use the videos this one
here we just playlist ID we grab the
playlist ID from this one here in our
JSON object in index dot HTML file so we
have another backtick to end this one
like so whoops we have an error here
yeah I misspelled this one it should say
parse like so so hopefully we'll have
our local storage saved in the same
state comes to do now is to modify or
state or initial state here we have to
check if we actually have this one or if
not we're going to use the videos so we
use a ternary operator here on every
property in the state so we check if we
have a same state if we have a safe
state we grab the values from the safe
state instead otherwise we grab it from
the videos Const say state said state
active video like so a bit repetitive
here but we have to do it safe state say
state dot night mode otherwise we can
set it to true as before and we have a
safe state say it state dot playlist ID
like so just making sure that I spelled
everything correctly here it looked like
so so say this one
and if we remove this one we clear out
the local storage we make a reload and
we change to video yeah three and we can
also wait for 10 seconds here to see if
it will save this one for us
so exchange the video 5 we can change
the night mode and if we look here it
should be saved now number 5
night more false and of video so if we
load this one yeah it's working so we've
learned how to persist a state it was
falyse in this application it's not that
much code to persist the state in local
storage in the next video we just going
to learn how to deploy this one we only
have to learn where to deploy this
sucker so in this video we'll do that if
we start in our app dot JS file you have
to think about the URL where you want to
host your application and for example
where I host it I have it at react
underscore video player like so so I
have it in a subfolder here and that's
very important cause we have to tell the
router in react that we have our
application in a subfolder so we go into
a PS file and inside you browse around a
component tag here you create a base
name equals and then forward slash and
your sub folder and a forward slash
again and this is only important if
we're going to use a sub folder if you
have it hosted at the root you don't
need to do this it's only if you have a
sub folder but it's likely that you're
going to have that I think so say this
one then we have to go into our package
JSON file you have a property called
home page and inside here you can just
write the whole complete URL to your
application so in my case it will be VM
file calm slash react video player so
put in your own URL there and also be
sure that you don't have a typing error
here you have to have a coma because
this is a new prop
in this object here sale is one and this
is really all there is to it no we have
to go into our console we have to break
or application here with ctrl + C and
then we just run npm run build and press
enter and create drag tap will create
this build folder for us as you can see
here it has built some files for us here
we go into our finder and you see we
have this new build folder so these are
the files that you just copied to your
server so grab this file and upload them
to your hosting server and it should
work and there's also one more thing you
have to think of and that's the dot h TX
s file and this is really where it can
look very different depending on hosting
company your server and where you're
going to host this one but I can just
show you what works in my case so I
create a new file here and I copy and
paste this one this one here goes in the
dot H the Access file in the folder
where you host your application what
this will do is it will always route
back to the index dot HTML on the server
cause we want or react application to do
the routing and this is really important
cause if you don't have this I've I've
had a lot of Heric with this things a
lot of times and if you don't have this
one it will not work it will probably
show you the start page but if you click
another video here it will throw an
error cause it won't find this one here
as it's in a subfolder and we also have
this ID here and it won't work because
it's trying to route this on the server
and we want to do this routing in the
application that's why we fall back to
the index dot HTML file so this is the
end of this course I hope you learned
something and I have had a blast
creating this one and showing this for
you hopefully I see you in my future
courses I intend to do a lot more of
them and I wish you all a great time and
happy coding Thanks
hi guys hope you enjoying the react
cooks course I thought I could show you
how to use the use cool back hook in
this little bonus video today so what
I've done here I set up a really simple
react app here it's just this button
that generates a random number here and
as you can see in my code here I just
have the app component and the button
component and of course the index so
what's going on here yeah in our app
we're using the hooks in a function of
component just as in the course and I
created a callback for the button so
when the button is clicked this callback
is invoked the button that receives the
callback and I also console.log what's
happening here so if we start looking at
the application and press the button
here you can see I console log out when
I click and I also console.log if the
button is rendered so first of all we
can just google use callback and go to
the react home page and we have it down
here and as you can see it returns and
memorized callback and this is because
in the functional components when you
remember the component it renders
everything again and if we look in our
code for example or app the case or app
component when this one rerun this it
will go through all of this code again
and create the callback over and over
again and there's also many that's using
inline functions here for the callback
like so and you do something new here
inside is and this anonymous function
will get recreated every time you click
so there will be a lot of these ones and
that's no good if you have a really
large application to be honest react
it's a pretty good and optimized library
so you don't have to worry about this
really but this a lot of people out
there worrying about recreating
functions and callback functions so what
we do in a regular class component we
can remove this one and just go back to
what it was before here and we just call
the function up here instead and then it
will not get recreated every time but
that's in the class components
they were different from the functional
components so we have to do something
else here for this one to not get
recreated every time and if we read a
little bit the use callback hook here
pass an inline callback and an array of
inputs use callback will return a
memorized version of the callback that
only changes if one of the inputs has
changed so you can kind of send in this
array here just like we did with the use
effect hook and this one will control
when the callback function will renew
itself and then if you don't want to
renew it just like we'd use effects you
can just send in an empty array so this
is useful when passing code back to
optimize char components that rely on
reference equality to prevent
unnecessary renders Iggy should
component update so when this one
creates a new call back on every render
even if the callback haven't changed the
char components will think that it's a
new prop that's being sent in and will
rerender and of course you have to do
something to control also what props are
being sent to your component but I'll
show you that in a second so what can we
do it because this one is being
recreated every time we click on this
one it creates a new one so we can
firstly import the use callback hook
like so just call back and then it is as
simple as just wrapping this one like so
and we also want to pass in an empty
array for this one because we're not
going to need to recreate this one you
just have this you state here that's
creating a random number when we click
this one so it should look the same all
the time we don't have to recreate it so
we just create this callback function
once and we do that by sending in an
empty array so if we say this one and we
click and we can see that nothing has
really changed here the callback
function itself is just created once but
we can't really see it now so we can
test this one by going to our button dot
JS file there's also one you think in
react they call react dot memo and this
one if you use the react memo it will
make this functional component to check
props and if the props are unchanged it
won't be render itself and this way you
don't have to import anything special
you just write react dot memo and you
wrap your component in that one like so
so if we click this one you can see that
we're not we rendering the component now
and that's good because before we had
this react memo say this one again you
can see I had this console log here
every time the app is rendered the
button component also get rear-ended but
by using the memo here like so we are
making sure that this component will
check the props before it decide if it
should rerender or not and because we
use the use callback hook here we are
not recreating this one in each render
so this will work now and as I said
there's not a lot of performance issues
here so you don't really have to do it
and that's why I didn't show this one
also in the course where we create a
video play because you not need to do
this in this kind of small applications
but it could be good to know what the
use callback is and now you know what it
is and what you can use it for so hope
this little bonus video was will have
something to do and you learned
something
I also hope you enjoy my reax course and
that it's going great you can also hook
me up on twitter at raven [ __ ] if you
want to I started to share small code
tips there especially in react but also
other things so this is it I hope you
enjoyed it see you